so as you all know I came out of
retirement even though I wasn't in
retirement
sort of like boxers do to play chess
I've been played a slow tournament in
six months and I played in the
Thanksgiving Open after changing my mind
five times and I took a half point by in
round one if you were here at the
previous lecture you'll saw my gaming
round two with Mario and this is my
round three game with Matt Larson
I guess the theme today for the middle
game planning is well in both games
I'm going to show you today I advance my
pawns on the Kings side with well the
main intent was to check my opponent but
in in more than one case my pawns were
used in to great effect not to checkmate
my opponent but to limit the opponent's
pieces by gaining space so sometimes
when your checkmating somebody you don't
need to check make them because you
haven't sacrificed any material you
haven't given anything away so you can
just use your space advantage by moving
your pawns forward to get an advantage
so I guess it's a middle game class so
we'll start in the middle game okay
there we go
so in both games we actually played a
lot of moves until there was a trade and
in fact in the next game we played more
than twenty was before there was a trade
so if you thought London was boring then
wait till you see this okay
now on this position black played an
interesting move that he could have
played earlier but since I didn't play
nine h4 there was no need for that a lot
of times in queen pawn openings this
Bishop is sort of trapped on c8 it may
have happened to you and so when you
play sort of a boring you know Zhu Kurt
or Kali like I'm doing black could sort
of do whatever he wants hopefully to his
detriment if he's playing me and
here he got his bishop out outside the
pawn chain on the other hand that bishop
could get trapped or captured it's not
going to get trapped in this variation
but often Knight h4 is played and I'll
get the two bishops advantage so here my
opponent played h6 which explains it
gives him an escape square and if you
were watching my game with Mario last
hour
Mario's Bishop was on c4 he retreated to
a - in similar fashion other side of the
board on their collar okay so since 94
doesn't make any sense because addition
of just goes to h7 I have to do
something else well the problem is when
you play d4 d5 openings somebody wants
to you know put something on one of
these squares with a pawn advance and
there's no way I'm going to play e4
because black has too many protectors if
I play c4 I'm not really sure what my
plan is so I decided to play on the
other side of the board and I played in
the center with 95 and I'll try to gain
some space on the Kings side my pawns
can move forward if you castles King
side and we could try to attack there
okay now one way to equalize in chess
which we're seeing a lot in London 25
games were played up until this point in
time of which we have 21 draws and 4
wins so those guys are good at defending
and so unfortunate that fidei has these
anti-cheating measures that's really bad
for chess because if you can't cheat and
you're all 2800 is all he gave is going
to be draws so we need to institute some
cheating methods where some of the
players can cheat sometimes there will
be some decisive results okay but since
there's no cheating at the top level and
they don't blunder we just see a lot of
draws luckily this is the Thanksgiving
open this isn't the London classic so
occasionally mistakes are made
occasionally like every game so my
opponent could do anything but he traded
which is fine and then he saw his knight
was attacked so he
it and again I can't play a four but my
opponents Bishop is pretty annoying on
f5 and if that Bishop wasn't there I
could start a King side attack so I'd
played Bishop to d3 and trade a bishops
okay so now I'm ready to play f4 f5 and
as Margo did against me and possibly f6
which Margo also did against me um and
my opponent doesn't have a lot of
counter plan the Queen side yet so what
I was worried about is that at some
point black would play f5 this was white
like what I feared and then if I don't
take it on passant I didn't see what my
plan would be and then he could just
push his Queen side pawns and I didn't
see like what I would do but take on
passant and he takes with the bishop and
we trade bishops how am I going to win
if we trade all the pieces off now here
f5 is somewhat risky because I'll play
Queen h5 check and you'll have to play
King f8 not like he wants to play King
f8 okay so he played a5 getting his
counter play started which was really
good actually
I played queen g4 just like it again my
comer showed Queen G for attacking g7
castles and unfortunately my bishop
can't go to h6 as of the game we just
looked at 30 minutes ago with my comer
okay but I knew I couldn't do that I was
going to play f4 and again if my
opponent can successfully play f5 then
I'm just totally blocked but he plays f5
here and I take now you're east six pawn
is hanging with check so you don't
really have time to do that
okay now here and again this is my
student he's been my student for five
years this is Matthew Larson when we
first started working together he was
rated about 1150 and now he's rated 2320
and he was in middle school we started
working together and now he goes to Yale
and we have lessons all the time on the
internet and in person fact I had
Thanksgiving at his home the day
before this game was played and we had a
lesson in the day before that and
sometimes he doesn't agree with what I
say and then sometimes he's writing
sometime right usually we're both wrong
and when when the game ended and we
discussed the game I said wow this will
really surprised me the move that he
played now he thought it was the most
normal move ever like what do you mean
like one of them of can I apply and well
okay the computer ended up agreeing with
me
it didn't understand this move at all
like I didn't so one for me
played rook e8 or he made seven thousand
was and arrows came that's what I meant
okay so that that didn't work out well
okay he played the computer was so
flabbergasted I wouldn't even play he
played rook e8 okay and the idea is he
wants to retreat one of his pieces to f8
simultaneously protecting his pawn on e6
so for example he could play Bishop FA
and then play f5 and I don't have any
Queen takes e6 anymore
or we could play Knight f8 with the same
kind of idea then play f5 and his
Knights defending e6
well computers not a big fan of rook e8
it just plays on the Queen side and
things black is doing fine Black's okay
after this okay and I played out five
and he played bishop f8 and now this was
another funny point of contention we had
sometimes people disagree I played f6
which I think sort of mildly surprised
him because I'm blocking everything up
but I thought I was taking so much space
and that he couldn't move and eventually
I would break through it turned out we
were both right because probably blacks
doing fine but he sort of let me break
through okay in g6
and now I made him move rather quickly
and then I sort of wondered why I played
it and a computer doesn't like it
I played Knight f3 I figure we got to
bring some pieces over there because I
can't made it with no pieces but the
thing is what am I going to do so he was
this thinking like I can do anything and
I was thinking I'll eventually do
something and again we were both right
now
one of the things we discussed was
something I think again I was right
about was there's a plan where where
white plays h5 and usually have to play
h4 first by being a grandmaster I can
just play h5n1 move right you agree
Danny yeah good job now he was wondering
at some point in the game why don't you
play h4 h5 now there were two reasons
one is he could play h5 after h4 but
that actually wasn't the reason
okay so let's pretend that black just
does nonsense
so rugby a h4 Rick a a h5 that looks
like White's doing something and I was
like okay you play g5 now I don't have
any pawn breaks so if I want to break
through I better sack on g5 which looks
like it must just win because that looks
really really good but it looks good but
what do I do
this isn't bug house this bug house then
I'll take white I can't do anything and
Bishop h6 is the next move and rugby g8
is the next move not appease so it looks
like no he's going to play Knight g5 and
you're getting crushed but I didn't
really see anything
well if h4 h5 doesn't work Who am I
supposed to do okay so when I played
Knight f3 and I was thinking what am I
going to do now I came up with sort of
an interesting plan my bishop on b2
isn't really attacking his king but as
in the my comer lecture if my bishop can
somehow get on the h6 pawn that that
would be better so I need to open up
this diagonal okay I need to play e4 at
some point put my bishop on that
diagonal put my Queen on h4 all right
then I'm in business okay so before the
business starts he plays Queen b6 or so
I thought
okay Queen to b6 attacking my e3 pawn
okay and I didn't like the fact that in
a lot of variations Knight c5 is coming
the bishop can come in here and I
thought if his pawn was on c5 that would
block two of his pieces they wouldn't
have access to those squares so after
Queen b6 I played Bishop to d4 which
sort of invites him to play see five
invitation accepted and then I retreated
and I was like well my pawns not
attacked anymore his Bishop doesn't
control these squares and his knight
can't go to c5 and I'm on my way to
playing Bishop d2 e four and we'll start
we'll start attacking him okay and this
is all fine you played a for attacking
my b3 pawn if it's free it's for me
I took it and again as my comer was
explaining in the last lecture there was
a position where white had a queen on
the Queen side
I'm sorry black actually was me as my
game black had it rook on a3 that was
defending a bishop on g3 pretty far away
and the same thing here the Queen's
defending the pawn so he plays Queen a6
attacking both of my pawns Rick a d1
then he takes my pawn so who thinks that
white should trade Queens time for white
to trade Queens I see a lot of head
shaking no that's just cuz you're not
feeling well today alright okay so ya
don't want to trade Queens because then
I probably won't checkmate them so I
play d4
okay now I've explained this to all of
my students someday someone will listen
to me maybe you at home though I doubt
it
normally when player 8 beats player B if
you're watching a television show or a
movie
the reason player a beats player B is
player a is better than player B so he
always wins okay however in real life
player a beats player B usually because
nothing special is going on and then
player B makes a horrible blunder okay
player a could have also made a blunder
and lost but player B decided to blunder
first in this game if you ask the engine
who has the advantage it says black has
a crushing advantage because it
things that white has a good attack
because computer only sees the actual
attack that's actually happening not
what you're afraid of
oh no I might get made it if you doesn't
think about that computer says I get
baited or I don't get made it if you
don't get mated then you're doing great
and the computers like man this bonds
are gone that pawn is finished and black
and start pushing his pawns fact
computer says after B five blacks close
to winning it really likes the move B
five now my plan doesn't work the reason
it doesn't work is very tricky
after b5 which is the best move a normal
move for white would seem to be Bishop
to d2 followed by my queen going to the
H file and then I actually do have a
good position but black has a winning
tactic here computers like winning
tactics humans
what's the winning tactic for black
there's some guy at home yelling sellout
I can hear them they're not yelling here
very staid here anyone winning tactic
winning material taking Knight takes e5
attacking my queen and then queen d4
check and black is a pawn up this pawn
on a2 is hanging
there's no attack there's nothing okay
now so actually white doesn't have a
threat here now hear my opponent made
the losing move and it actually takes
engines awhile to realize that's losing
but I realize it eventually played the
move d4 or he did nothing okay
and after the move d4 black doesn't have
this counter play he doesn't have Queen
d4 check ever and he's blocking the
center you don't want to block the
center when your opponent's check me you
like the center open now my opponent's
thought differently okay maybe he works
for Apple okay and he thought I want to
take this pawn because I like taking
pawns maybe I'll play Queen c2 and take
the pawn with the rook but then there's
some counter play for white and taking
these pawns
the center this pawn can't take back as
his knights hanging I'm going to get rid
of White's Center counterplay and then
I'll just went on the Queen side my
opponent has nothing on the Kings side
that's what he was thinking
so he played d4 and I played Bishop to
d2 and now my next move was either Queen
h4 or queen h3 and he's in a lot of
trouble for example if Queen takes a 2
Queen h4 King h7 that looks like it
defends unfortunately it doesn't I just
take the pawn and if you take Knight g5
check and I slightly prefer white
slightly okay especially since I have
the white pieces so that doesn't work so
instead he played the move Queen to c2
now again I'm sort of lucky because what
I wanted to do didn't work and after
thinking about 8 minutes the last like
40 seconds of my think I found the
correct move and he never saw the
correct move and when I played it he was
like wow that's a good move he is very
impressed now many of you will be super
confused of these variations I know I
was so what I wanted to do was I wanted
to play Queen g6 check at the
appropriate moment ok the appropriate
moment is when this nights not here and
then I could play f7 check for King as
king and rook and this work has already
taken on a 2 so I'm trying to figure how
I can accomplish that well there's an
issue so let's say I don't move let's
play the move what doesn't move h4 okay
and then if my opponent plays rook takes
a 2 and I play a move like 91 and the
idea of 91 is in a Texas Queen and now I
want to play Queen takes pawn check for
example let's move the Queen away Queen
takes pawn shack clean and I'm a genius
ok I win ok so I'm trying to figure out
how to do that problem is if I don't
make a move and then I play 91 plays
Knight takes e5
and me I'm not playing Queen SIG's g6
anymore
also my queen needs to defend my rook on
d1 so this is just I lose everything I
could take his queen takes my queen
or I could play Queen e2 and he loses
Queen away and I'm down to pawns so I'm
like okay I have to stop Knight takes e5
so then it came to me what if I play
Queen g3 that stops Knight takes e5 now
when he plays rook takes pawn I can't
play 91 as my rooks hanging well my
queen was on g4 it defended my rook
and now if I take it's possible he can
play King h8 here possible especially
since like my bishop is hanging and I'm
down like five pieces okay then it came
to me since 91 hangs of my rook let's
play Knight takes d4 that doesn't hang
my rook that if he takes and then we're
back into my great variation where white
wins and I was thinking to myself which
I shouldn't be doing but what was
supposed to do I was thinking yeah he's
not going to see that so if I play Queen
g3 he will play rook takes a two he's
not gonna see Knight takes d4 right and
then I was like well wait a minute after
Knight takes d4 wow that went back more
than usual that was you know this is
good computer okay I was thinking after
Knight takes d4 in this position what if
he doesn't take my knight and plays I
don't know Queen a4 and the idea is
after tanks just play King h8 now my
queen actually is hanging because I
don't have a check and my nights hanging
and my nights hanging with check and my
e5 pawn is hanging and I was like I
don't know what the computers gonna say
about this I know I don't know so I was
looking at all those variations and then
I realized I have two problems my e5
pawn is hanging when I move my knight
and when his Queen and rook around the
seven
drink that's annoying so I solved both
problems but took me forever to find
this move and when I played it he
realized he was losing in fact if you
have an engine like stockfish Okamoto
and you put this position it says Queen
c2 equals it says it's equal and then
when it finds the winning movement
thanks for five minutes it says why it's
completely winning but it's so again I
want to stop the counter play of Knight
takes e5 and I want to stop the counter
play of RIP takes 800
so I played Bishop f4 and the idea is
there's never going to be a knight takes
e5 I'm sorry about that anymore and I
don't have to worry about his rook and
Queen mating because I play rugby too
and get rid of his rocker
so he'll have no counter play and I'll
start to meet him and coincidentally my
pawn was hanging here on d3 but not now
so I got to do everything okay so he
thought a long time and when the
computer thinks a long time it realizes
that White's winning it's very hard to
take time out and play a slow move when
you're playing for me but it's much
easier to do that when you haven't
sacrificed a lot of material when you
sacrifice a piece and you're trying to
checkmate your opponent and you play
slow moves your opponent's a piece up
here I'm down upon arm down nothing I'm
done nothing right yeah so I haven't
sacrificed anything so I don't have to
meet him I can just play chess this
should before all made it when I feel
like it which is going to be really soon
okay so he took a pawn he's finally upon
a head I trade rooks so there's no more
counter play for him on the sevens right
and now this is actually very funny the
difference between Queen h4 and Queen h3
one wins and one doesn't really win okay
and most of the variations I looked at
this game but with Queen h3 so you never
mates me on g2 I don't want to get me an
NG - okay however in this instance Queen
h4 is much better okay and the reason is
very simple the only defense to his H
pawn is the move h5 when he plays h5
what am I going to do to
better him on h5 and you want how do i
crush h5g for after g4 if he takes on g4
I'll play Knight g5 and he'll resign
that's a nice variation and queen h7
mate
I like that variation because I'm white
okay
and the very small difference of my
queen being on h3 is now Knight g5 is
not so good my Queens hanging and I
can't play Queen h4
and then Knight g5 takes mine so I have
to actually take and then go back to the
age file in ingot though this cost you
like two or three Tempe just the small
difference of going h3 or h4 okay so I
play Queen h4 and it's over now if he
plays g5 I can take with the bishop and
then take with a knight and queen HF and
mate is coming if you play King h7 I
take the pawn and play Knight g5 check
as in the previous variation we looked
at so here there's just nothing to do
okay
but he's 2300 so he finds something he
plays for tricks tricks don't work
against me why is that Bensimon that's
correct
and he played Queen to e2 would someone
like to explain how that stops me from
meeting him when I play Bishop h6 Queen
h6 Queen g7 mate what does Queen e2 do
about that threat
anyone any knows but you won't say yeah
I could see you knew well what is this
uh is this marathon me and you know the
intern you won't say it yeah you guys
know what I'm talking about yes not
typical Bridal okay so if this should
age six Bishop h6 Queen age chicks with
unstoppable me Queen III check with
unstoppable Queen trade after which
white has a slight advantage right okay
but I wasn't born at night or last night
whatever is funnier so I played Ricky
one and now Queen III check will always
be risky because I'm gonna take away my
rook okay he took his free pawn and I
took my free pawn except now I'm going
to checkmate him
black has three connected passed pawns
perhaps I should resign okay so yeah
everything is checkmate for me now I can
play Queen h7 mate
I can play Queen g7 mate it's hard to
stop any of them I'm just getting in
there okay so now instead of resigning
he sacrificed his Knight and I was like
okay I'll take it and then he played
Queen to c3 now Queen c3 doesn't attack
my rook because my rooks protected but
after something like takes takes now if
I play Queen h6 it's unstoppable mate
except he's first Queen takes for
command then I would meet him and it's a
draw right okay so instead I played
Knight f3 which does two things
first of all I want to protect my rook
so I can you know give him the mate
second of all I don't want him to stop
me from eating him and the way to stop
it is Queen to d2 that would protect
aged six so Knight f3 stops everything
and if I don't like Queen h6 Queen g7
maybe cuz it's not my style
I could play Knight g5 and Queen h7 mate
either way is good okay so he designed
so that that made actually worked out
but only because my opponent played d4
and closed the center thinking with the
center closed he could win on the Queen
side which was true but I went on the
Kings side which he was not expecting
he thought add that attack won't work
well he did win on the Queen side my
queen
gone I got nothing but the King side
attack broke through hooray for the good
guys okay please play more of a good guy
than I am all right now another game
this was the last round yeah flip board
okay I was black in the last round
against Nick Carlo and I need to win
because if I don't win then they don't
give you my money so and I've played
Nick many times and we had a draw once
and I was successful the other times
so the Nicollet I know plays Knight f3
g3 Bishop g2 that's all he does but he
tricked me by d4 I was like d4 ok and I
play everything so I wanted to follow
the the Kaspari off method now as all of
you know and either the third or fourth
match the Karpov played Kasparov nobody
knows which one even they don't know
they've played so many matches they
can't remember and one of the matches
Karpov was ahead 12 to 11 with one game
to go and Kasparov was the reigning
world champion so if he ties the match
he keeps his title so basically if
Kasparov wins he's their world champion
and if he draws her losses carpetas and
because far up was white and he played
boring Radia made the game go $1,100 in
position very quickly so basically the
game was about equal for a long time and
after several hours Karpov started to
miss please' position he lost so I
decided I would want a game that's not
too exciting but will go on and on and
on and on it's sort of a fast time
control and maybe if Nick got in time
trouble or just if the game went 60 70
80 moves he would make lots of mistakes
so I wasn't trying to win right away and
Nick was playing very solid so we had a
very very solid London system boring
nothing going on note
rains okay and if you remember my last
game and it was like three minutes ago
so I was pushing my pawns for King side
attack and my opponent was pushing his
pawns for Queen side attack and we both
sort of broke through luckily maid is
more important and this happened in this
game also so I can't play e5 right now
because White has a lot of things on e5
and I actually couldn't see the
difference between playing Queen e8
followed by e5 and then Queen e7 or
playing e6 Queen e75 I was like well if
I play Queen ei I better play e5 yt6
maybe I won't they'll change my mind so
I'd play d6 and of course I did not
change my mind okay
Queen c2 is really slow and doesn't
really do anything I think you should
push his Queen side bonds then I play d5
rook FD won again I don't know why the
rooks on d1 it's slow so blacks
equalized pretty easily and now I
decided to take the initiative and when
I was originally thinking about ePHI
Vandy for I was thinking well I want to
play f5 but that's illegal and then I
was wondering if my Grandmaster talked
about me you do get it but I probably
not so I ended up to play 9h 598 or move
my H pawn and then play Knight h7 well
move you my H pawn in playing 9 h7 loses
a tempo I want to buy Knight right now 9
h5 could take my night on h5 or play g4
later and I like 98 the reason I like 98
is when he's crashing down the Queen
side my Knights actually defending the
Queen side I actually like my 98 okay so
he crashes on the Queen side I went on
the Kings side he wouldn't on the Queen
side and well I'm sort of worried he's
going to keep pushing his pawns I'd like
it to be blocked up
so I played a6 and if he pushes either
pawn I'll push the other one and block
up the Queen side although that's what I
was expecting I was expecting this this
this and this and I'll try to play this
next to my
and then I'll try to meet him on the
Kings side when he can't really do
anything on the Queen side my night on e
8 is stopping him from infiltrating ok
well instead he played rook a B 1
because he wanted to get off this
diagonal and I'm like ok and I played
the move Bishop h6 because I want to
play f4 but not because I want to crash
through with my F pawn with my e pawn so
the idea is if I play at 4 and he takes
it I'll play e3 and he didn't want me to
do that so he played Knight to f1
stopping my pawn from going to e3 ok and
I'm like good his lights on f1 his
Knights going to come on the Queen side
and take everything so now I'm back on
the Kings side he's back on the Queen
side I'm on the Kings side he's on the
Queen side so the extra reminded me of
my game with me Larsson because I'm
losing on the Queen side but I have a
good position on the Kings side I'm
probably not going to checkmate him
because White has so many pieces in
front of his king his knights and
bishops are there on the other hand I
like the fact that his bishop is trapped
it's these that exerting pressure here
okay then White has an obvious threat
White's threat is yep forking my bishop
at night so I play Bishop to d5 after
the game I told him I thought his next
move was a mistake but the computer says
it's fine Bishop c4
I thought the bishop was really well
placed on this diagonal stopping me from
going forward and I defended my bishop
and one of the things the computer wants
white to do which neither one of us ever
considered because we're human is the
move h4 and I'm certain if I was playing
a stronger player someone in the top 20
or 30 in the world they would certainly
think of them with h4 and probably play
it and the idea is after a trade this
Knight has a really really nice III
square some would say too nice like me
that's a nice square for your knight
ok but usually when your opponent's
trying to make sure you don't play h4
question no question okay so so my
opponent instead started trading on the
queenside played CB six and he played
rook to c1 he's infiltrating on the
Queen side but but where I played ninety
eight so he can't come in there okay now
I made two Grandmaster moves this game
I'm not saying they were good was there
just was grandmasters play that you guys
don't your moves are probably better
than mine but I got the title so okay so
to any Grandmaster this is a very
obvious move but I wouldn't expect
anybody here to suggest it and it might
not even be the best move it's just a
move that is like obvious to me I don't
want my King on g8 because my bishop is
pinned and he could check me on the
diagonal and all kinds of bad stuff
could happen also since his bishop
abandoned this diagonal I'm going to
play g4 and I'm going to crash through I
want to play rook g8 in some positions
so I play King h8 okay my ricky'll go to
GA I'll never get checked to me it's
just an obvious move okay now instead of
being subtle and trying to inch his way
in and do stuff
he once sort of whole hog took queen c6
with this fork but black has many ways
to escape this fork we can put one of
the Knights on c7 either night or the
move that I play Knight to f6 defending
my knight and a very drunken way and
defending my rook okay and again he
forges no rawr and I block it up so his
Queen side counter play doesn't look
very impressive there's nothing he can
do at his bishop on h2 is blocked his
Knights are very passive and I have a
lot of space now unlike a lot of games
where I'm sacrificing all my pieces to
checkmate my opponent in the Matt Larson
game and this game and sacrifice
anything materials even if I don't made
them it's okay I still have a space
advantage okay
my opponent played g4 which I thought
was pretty reasonable because I think
I play g4 that's not good for him I'm
going to crash through I might even take
here first and then my bishops going to
be on this diagonal actually think g4 is
okay and here I played for a trick and
luckily it worked now again I can't
challenge the C file because he has the
C file he'll he'll take my Rux play rook
c8 either rook he'll he'll take my rook
and he'll have to record Queen totally
dominate the C file so I played Queen e6
because I can play on the C file also
and now my opponent made a tactical
error although if he sees the tactics
and defense against them the computer
already gives black and almost winning
advantage because my opponent's bishop
on h2 isn't very good it's trapped his
Knights are sort of passive and I have a
lot of space I haven't sacrificed
anything in my long-term plan that I was
thinking of during the game was to move
my bishop and play h5 and continue
attacking okay but if they make a
tactical mistake then we'll we'll take
some material Gate played 9 g2 and now I
have a strong tactic based on fact that
I can now go to the C file now that I
have all those pieces on the C file now
of course if I attack his Queen and is
rook that's a skewer
unfortunately that rook is defended so
let's undefended let's try to make this
rook move away from this rug Knight
takes b4 was played and if he doesn't
take my knight I'm threatening his Queen
and night d3 is pretty good so he takes
my ayat and I attack his queen and rook
now problem with playing this rook is
that this with the idea of protecting
this pawn is he can stay on my other
Rock and if I take this rook takes that
rug so that doesn't work but rook AC it
works and I thought he would take this
and then take on b5 he would have a pawn
for the exchange but my rook pinning his
knight his Bishop being trapped
night being trapped all three of his
minor pieces trapped I didn't I didn't
believe that okay computer agrees so he
went into crazy mode which was a good
mode when you're losing it's a pawn on
f4 I took his queen and he took my rook
so he has a ruck and a knight for a
queen and he's threatening to take
things and push things and take things
and everything to take so I thought a
long time computer doesn't like what I
did which is good it makes the game
interesting I attacked his rook and I
attacked his other rook and if he saves
his rook then I'm going to take this and
he's just crushed for example black has
no play white has no play at all again
all his pieces are terrible so he
sacrificed more material as I expected
and the main line that I analyzed during
the game was he would take on g5 I would
take the rook threatening the other rook
he would take the pawn threatening my
queen and my bishop I would play Queen
f7 and he would play rook f6 as I was
analyzing this I finally dawned on me
that I could play Queen a - the idea is
if you take my bishop your rook is
hanging and if you take my rook I can
save my bishop and if you play rook
takes then that's why I played Queen a -
I actually had a reason okay
so I really like that variation for
black the engines later agreed and he
didn't play F takes G five he played F 5
which is much better because now I don't
have any counter play down here so I
took his rook and he took my pawn I
saved my queen he took my bishop and I
took his center pawn and the material is
this ship and a knight and upon for a
queen now I showed this game in my
advanced kids class when I say advanced
it's not too advanced and I said what's
worth more a Bishop Knight in a pawn or
a queen and the whole class said this
should lighten barn that's why it wasn't
so advanced that I beg to differ
so okay so Queens better than the
have been tonight and black actually has
something very good in this position
other than having an extra queen is I
have this past B pawn and there's very
few white pieces in front of it I would
say none now his pawn I got all of my
pieces stopping it so I'm not super
worried about that okay but he's might
want to worry about that okay and in
fact I I did queen that pond because I
wanted to okay so I thought he was going
to play something like a Bishop d6 or
Rick d6 but he played rookie six he
wants to play Bishop e5 check and win my
queen
so I played 93 which defends and attacks
also it gets out of the way of my pawn
so he defended f2 and I play King to g8
this was my second GM move of the game I
think actually the computer likes that
move so I don't want my King on h8
because bad stuff might happen on g8 bad
stuff won't happen and again I'm not in
a hurry to win I'm in a hurry to not let
him trick me so King GA is really safe I
don't see how you could ever do anything
okay and then I started cleaning my pawn
and I kept quitting my pawn and then I
kept queening my pawn it seemed like
good idea and he played his one trick
which I had foreseen he checked and now
Bishop e5 is almost made but my knight
on d3 can take his Bishop so he took my
knight now if it was his move this
should be five and I would lose I would
play rook f6 he would take it was mate
but I had foreseen this and I had a
really nice way of stopping Bishop e5 by
getting a queen and then my Queens toss
Bishop e5 Queen takes which piece is it
okay it's okay he actually could play
King age too but there's no reason not
to take and then you could move his king
and again this should be five you got to
watch out so what
while I get mated yeah like this is made
so I got it like not to do that okay so
instead of giving my Queen away I didn't
give my Queen away I made a queen now
I'm two queens ahead which is nice and
I'm threatening Queen takes Knight
leading to mate Queen takes rook and
pawn takes rook as they would say in
Hughes favorite movie good luck
so after queening he resigned hmm who
what question
Oh taken yeah I didn't want to want to
give him any credit cause you know then
now they're going to sue us yeah so that
was funny that I was trying to made him
than he was trying to meet me that
wasn't very nice okay and my bathing
attack was sort of stopped because of
his blunder I had to win on the Queen
side but if they get a blunder I went on
the Queen side so now I'm threatening me
and everything and luckily I could
defend e5 so that was good because it
was the last round always good to win
the last round sometimes you lose the
last round then you drive home seven I
was wondering why you lost the last
round yeah now my favorite story in that
ilk is I was in Chicago
playing in the Chicago Open make sense
and my son was also playing and if I won
the last round I want a class prize this
sounds like this is a 30 year old story
well this is a four year old story and
they had an under 2500 feet a prize and
I was twenty four ninety and I was like
under 2500 feet a prize I like that I
don't when class prizes do often so the
last round I was playing a lower rated
Grandmaster and I had black and if I won
I would win like a thousand dollars or
something so the game went six hours
where I was slightly better the whole
game with black but never winning there
was a draw so I want nothing and you
would think it's time to go home because
my six hour game is done but that would
be incorrect
because I came with somebody and they
were still playing my six hour game was
the shorter of
two games and my son was playing out
ciao al Chow is a 2,300 player former
2300 player from Chicago and my son was
an expert and their game went six hours
and 15 minutes with my son winning at
the end and didn't win any money but
usually when you drive home several
hours after a long tournament you both
are lying and we lost the last round
usually that's the way it goes but this
way I was upset but he was ecstatic that
he was paired up and won a game over six
hours and that I was doing all the
driving so he had everything yeah so he
took a nice nap while I slept and I also
took a nice nap but don't tell anybody
that yeah especially the cops so that
was my first slow tournament in six
months hopefully I'll play another one
in less than six months it's possible
also possible I won't and I was able to
win in the last round because I was
pared down so if you learn nothing from
this lecture and you didn't get paired
down in the last round don't get paired
up that's tough